as we reported yesterday all five
officers charged to Nichol's death were
part of a specialized anti-crime unit so
we asked our senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge to look
at how these controversial task forces
have become part of big city policing
the Memphis Police Department's scorpion
unit was intended to be an elite
specialized unit in response to the
city's High violent crime and homicide
rate but the five Memphis police
officers charged in Tyree Nichols death
were new to the force and a former
Memphis police officer tells CBS News
the Scorpion unit training consisted of
just three days of PowerPoint
presentations one day of suspect
apprehension training and one day at the
firing range the department did not
immediately respond to CBS news's
questions these units require
significant supervision something that
was apparently missing in the Scorpion
unit former NYPD commissioner Bill
Bratton says there appear to be many
missteps you want more seasoned offices
three four five six years on the job so
you can look at their track record and
you want to select them carefully and
then most importantly training training
and training and that is the Achilles
heel of American police forces in every
area of responsibility while there is no
official data on the number of
anti-crime units Nationwide similar
issues have played police departments in
other major cities Atlanta police's
anti-drug unit known as red dog was shut
down in 2011 after officers were accused
of using excessive force during a
traffic stop and a raid on a gay bar he
pulled out the handgun in Baltimore's
gantre's task force seen here in this
body camera video was disbanded after
eight officers were convicted of
racketeering and extortion Memphis
unfortunately is dealing with a perfect
storm that American policing is dealing
with in various
amounts around the country after the
death of George Floyd in Minneapolis
Bratton says senior officers left
policing and departments are desperate
for recruits at this time in the crisis
of American policing you actually want
to raise the standards not lower them
and so everything that could go wrong
seems to have gone wrong in the
circumstance for CBS mornings Catherine
Herridge Washington